hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen dot review heute stelle ich
euch den radar bz player show what vor
welcher euch spieler und mops auf einer
kleinen mini karte zeigt viel spaß so
hier befinden wir uns nun im menü von
minecraft und zwar werden wir uns mal
eben eine neue welt erstellen die
einfach mal new world das ist relativ
egal im creative dann wird ihn nun
created und zwar wollte ich euch das
ganze in einer neuen welt zeigen damit
ihr seht dass dort nicht nur jobs
gezeigt werden wo ich bin noch in der
501 ist sehr schön und zwar wenn ihr auf
1 drückt habt ihr ganz normal diesem
modus wenn ihr wieder auf 1 druck ist da
oben auf einmal diese komische karte
ihr seht da nun diese karte mit diesem
schwarzen hintergrund wo alle möglichen
mops beziehungsweise auch spieler wenn
ihr auf ein multiplayer server seite
angezeigt werden
und das ist ganz interessant weil dann
seht ihr sofort wo zum beispiel eine
höhle sein könnte zum beispiel wenn ich
mal da zeige david hundertprozentig eine
höhle seien hier auch weil dort sind
ziemlich viele mops wird können wir
gleich einmal hinfliegen und was ich
auch ganz interessant finde ist dass
dort sap links und kisten angezeigt
werden das heißt hier liegt jetzt zb sap
linken auf die karte des tales weg wenn
ich jetzt hier über pflege
hier sollte irgendwo eine kiste sein da
kann ich mir einfach warte ich mal so
mit nach unten graben einfach damit ihr
seht dass das ganze auch vertrauensvoll
ist eine fackel
ich höre schon spinnen so wenig
luftdruck details sind wir hier bei
einem spanner das sieht man daran weil
da oben sind mehrere spinnen und hier
ist die kiste die oben angezeigt wurde
wenn ich die abbau ist die obenauf weg
da liegen dann die items rum und so
weiter als es auf jeden fall ziemlich
ziemlich geil dass sie immer so genau
sofort ist wo genau was ist wenn jetzt
natürlich nicht wisst dann befindet ihr
euch diesen motor nicht holen also dass
zum thema ihr seht wirklich genau wo
welcher mob ist wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel diese scharf da hinten was da
hinten oder diese drei oder vier alter
wie viele schafe sind da wenn ich dir
jetzt mal haben möchte dann fliegt
einfach rüber oder sondern eine kiste
hier irgendwo müssten hier irgendwo
gleich schafe
kommen genau hier da sind auch die habe
ich gar nicht gesehen bei dem schnee
hier sind auch schon die schafe also ihr
seht echt immer genau wo mob sein
könnten wenn ihr zb länder perle braucht
seht ihr da oben ist ein ende am ende
fliegen hin warum da genau so ein blog
grad herum liegt weiß ich nicht
vielleicht ist das travel oder so aber
das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen
dass da einfach so ein blog rumliegt ich
bin genau drauf
na gut okay vielleicht ist hier drunter
irgendwo eine höhle wo dann eventuell
irgendwo im block rumliegt oder so ich
schaue mal ganz okay cool hier sollte
dann irgendwo in greven blog herumliegen
oder so anders kann ich mir das nicht
erklären aber ihr seht halt echt immer
genau wo welche mops sind so wir
befinden uns nun hier im multiplayer
menü von minecraft wir gehen mal kurz
auf den mythen show servern ich zusammen
mit dem supplier habe für die mythen
show ich wollte noch dumm so vorhin
sagen dass er doch mal kurz drauf kommen
soll wenn man da oben auch spieler sieht
im sieht im multiplayer
aber der war gar nicht online von daher
mache ich das gerade mal hier sehen zum
beispiel hier das schaf direkt hier
peter nach wie geht's dir peter kennen
wahrscheinlich einige noch und man sieht
halt auch im multiplayer funktioniert
das ganze auch ich kann da eben rüber
fliegen sehen wir schon hier sind ein
paar spinnen das skelett was ich im
wasser übers leben hält blödmann stirbt
ich freue mich so gut eur je nicht und
was ich auch noch sagen wollte es unter
der minimap wartet ich mach das mal kurz
so dann seht ihr die mini mehr probleme
so sind jetzt besser unter der minimap
habt ihr hier die koordinaten wenn ich
mal f3 drücke seht ihr das ganz links
die iks koordinate steht in der mitte
die y koordinaten und ganz rechts set
also an alle die die es nicht wissen y
ist die höhe also wenn ich hoch springen
wie ich auf 9 60 auf 68 jetzt gehe ich
runter 760 xs die weiter nach da bzw
nach ihr dann erhöht sich das gucken auf
die karte dann wir diese erste zahl der
kleiner beziehungsweise größer und die
ganz rechts ist genau das gegenteil also
die richtung in diese richtung jetzt
wird auch gerade schon nacht und das war
es auch schon mit dieser mode review wo
ist der untergang der untergang
ich würde mich definitiv über einen
daumen hoch freuen wenn es euch gefallen
hat oder einen kommentar mit entweder
eurem skin oder einem einem mod
vorschlag und dann werde ich das nächste
mal eventuell euren skin benutzen und
sich beschwerte sich dass er so selten
mache aber ich kann nicht in jeden nicht
jedes mal den skin and
es wäre zu viel arbeit mit dem programm
das sich da habe paint und naja
jedenfalls werde ich demnächst mal
wieder euren skin anziehen und dann noch
einen schönen tag und viel spaß mit
diesem motto